on peut très bien les laisser en maillot
de bain mais à côté arrêter de faire une
minutes d'interview on ne sait pas ce
qu'ils ont dans la tête on sert l'idée
de les voir défiler quelque chose je
veux dire quelque chose il ya eu quatre
interventions sur les miss france 4
mauvaise j'aimerais bien en avoir une
bonne 30k piron non mais ça sera pas mal
mais non non non le sait que j'avais 15
ans de travail avec vous je le sais mais
non tu as paieront évidemment que non ce
n'est pas parce que ces photos là c'est
sûr le plus racé que d'autres peut-être
qu'ils font enlever les femmes allaient
me sens maintenant n'oublions pas que
cesse ça fait partie de la tradition
mais bon on arrête miss france elle est
à fond et drake aussi miss france existe
il faut que ce soit complètement à fond
donc qu'elles sont mayuma je vois pas où
est le côté sexisme en faut qu'on
m'explique
la pression je suis seulement en tant
qu'individu juste pour l'argent ni sinon
si on l'abandonné chéri ici on lève la
main beaucoup la parole si on sait
maintenant on est deux on est sûr m
radio ici c'est le mets sur me juger
uniquement qu'avec les photos en maillot
de bain je serais d'accord mais c'est
pas ça oui on les voit plein de domaines
donc je vois pas pourquoi la dominance
cash en maillot de bain ça c'est même
franchement je le sais dit la vérité
deux minutes je ne crois pas en tout on
attend je te le dis maintenant ce que tu
veux et isaac monde à naples une ânerie
en nous car oui tu es mon avis je te le
dis of là les gens nous attendent pas et
je ne crois pas un instant
non mais c'est où se voit après des
missions et peut-être ou bien toi tu
veux tu es sûr tu veux parler maintenant
oui alors attendez l'intervention
d'isabelle with a été très intelligent
mais en revanche stéphanie tu confonds
le féminin et le cynisme je lui pardonne
moi si c'est si ringard on se cherche
ring pourquoi tu as toujours de
décolleté qui
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas demandé à ce qu'on en juge sur
des critères physiques et jeux pour vous
répondre
elles font quoi dire alors en tout cas
dans les eaux minutes maya l'abeille
tabac me sondage suis pas super sexy moi
je peux pas me présenter au concours
miss france donc je m'assume justement
et c'est ça justement être féministe
c'est que je m'assume en tant que femme
et que je suis pas baser uniquement sur
des critères physiques et qu'est ce que
font d'autres alors pendant le concours
à part défilé à part et on m'a fait des
phrases beaucoup trop long il va voter
sur guingamp b alors je te reste